hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in round five
of the 2018 isle of man chess tournament
and it features an even nicer theme now
I remember that was really really a long
time ago some maybe twelve years ago or
more I was going through
borislav Boris lava if covers a theory
of end end games and I came up to this
theme I was a to Knights against the
king can you win this game or is that a
draw and when I first saw this I was a
very impressed by it and I'm sure for
many this is also going to be a very a
very enjoyable experience so without
further ado let's check out this very
nice game I just want to mention one
thing and in the previous video I made a
video on Gawain Jones against Lucas Dee
and I said how it was a I didn't know
how come he only has one letter for a
surname
but it is actually not his surname a
couple of excellent subscribers sent me
an email explaining to me why there is
only one letter so I decided to share
this with you now his name is GU Kish
and he they said that sometimes after
the 1950's it became unpopular to have a
surname in certain parts of India so
instead would instead of having a
surname they just have a name like guca
in for example in this case and the D is
the first letter of his father's name so
a a similar example is for example a how
much Bobby pregnant lambda his name is
pregnant Honda and before he became
really famous like he is now he was
known to be pregnant on the are but as
he is now famous he's now pregnant under
Ramesh Babu as Raj Babu is the name of
his father so I thought that was a very
nice increase of my own vast knowledge
so decided to share that with you as
well now getting back to this game
kurakin opens the game would eat four
and it's not it's a really a nice game
you know a nice crew Lopez game every
rule opus game is a nice game but you'll
see what I mean and okay e5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop to b5 the rule opus as
we've said
a six more fees defense our worship to a
four Knight to f6 we have castles Bishop
to e7 and rook to e1 still the standard
theory of the real hope is Murphy's
defense b5 Bishop to b3 we have castles
and now a four seven Percy's would be
four and we have a five by kurakin we
have D 6 D 3 Bishop to e6 challenging
the bishop on B 3 and we have a knight B
to d2 and ok Queen to see it we have h 3
rook to b8 and now Knight to c4 so you
can see this is a very nice set up by
kurakin he has a knight on c4 he has a
knight on f3 which is a lot of pressure
on this ePHI pawn and it will make it
very difficult for black to ever
actually execute the d5 as there's
really no good way to add further
protection to the e5 pawn okay we have h
6 by 7 Bishop to e3 this is nothing new
this has been played plenty and plenty
of times
rook the d8 and now Queen - e - we have
Bishop to f8 Knight f2 d2 and here it's
a very interesting in 2006 Cara can
already had this position against the 11
Aragon in vikon Z and here are none
preceded with Knight d2 e7
sorry Knight see - e7 and also Irina had
this position with the black pieces also
in 2006 in Linares against Peter Svidler
and in that game Ireland proceeded would
would Queen to b7 so we have this two
very known moves in this position and
Knight seat CT e7 and also Queen to b7
but in this game seven plays g6 and this
is a move that was never played before
and this position has never been seen
before in the database so this is now a
completely new game some of you said
that you enjoy when I mentioned this so
there you have it this is a completely
new game and it's very interesting how
both these moves that were already
played instead of g6 97 and Queen to b7
I have to do something with them the
undefended knight on c6 and this is
exactly how Kirk in you know continues
the game first brush up to a four he
attacks the undefended knight on c6
Quinta b7 defending it and now comes the
Queen to f3 now attacking the knight on
f6 but also the bishop on e4 and the
queen that is x-raying the knight on c6
so perhaps in the future moves like
maybe d4 and d5 creating a double attack
against the c6 Knight perhaps it will be
possible but who knows it's it's a very
active position from that arise from a
rule opus nice - h7 getting the knight
out of the way and now Queen to g3 again
making it kind of hard for black to
execute this defy breakthrough as this
Knight and queen are now giving a lot
more pressure to the e5 pawn Bishop to
g7 adding more defense to d5 pawn and
now comes f4 so white is definitely
creating something here and if you're
able to create a pawn break especially
against a central pawn and your position
doesn't deteriorate you are doing
something right and oke captures on f4
Bishop captures on f4 and now comes
Knight to f6 it would be it would be
very nice for black if he could get nice
to h5 in to attack the Queen and the
bishop and get rid of Corrections dark
square Bishop so hurricane moves it
Bishop to e3 and now comes Knight to d7
we have Queen back to f2 and now comes
nice to see five it's interesting but
this is not a pawn sacrifice because you
can't capture here if you play Knight
Bishop captures then pawn captures and
Queen captures will lose you the Queen
of course after Bishop to d4 trick you
have to move the King or capture the
bishop and black wins the Queen and the
game of course
so after Knights to c5 Bishop captures
on c6 Queen captures on c6 and now comes
the Bishop to d4 offering a trade of
dark square bishop but she captures
Queen captures and now comes b3 getting
rid of this week pawn on b4 and arlynn
sorry Kerrigan has to decide what to do
here he pushes c3 and now comes Knight
back to d7 the knight did everything it
needed to do here and now at some point
he wants to remover it's the e5 Queen to
e3
attacking the weak h6 spawn and here a
very interesting moment 7 decides not to
defend the h6 pawn via King to g7 or
working to h7 which definitely is is the
way to go but rather he decides to go
for a central pawn breakthrough with d5
and okay each chapters on d5 Bishop
captures on d5 and here Queen captures
on h6 kurakin snatches upon so what's
the deal here can black capture the pawn
and g2 well in fact yes he can but it's
not not all that impressive a move for
example Bishop captures Angie to roughly
two attacks the bishop now the bishop is
attacked twice we're the rook and the
King Bishop has to move back now comes
rook a to e1 for the price of that G to
pawn white now creates a powerful rook
battery along the e-file and now let's
say play Bishop captures Knight captures
it will be a very difficult position to
play for black and not not something you
want to go for although the engine likes
it but you know engines or engines
Samuel sibian is not an engine he's a
human
so after Queen captures on age six he
decides to go first
rook to e8 and okay we have knife to e3
by Karen and again a very difficult
position for black car I can manage to
snatch a pawn and if you don't gain
something out of it he will eventually
lose upon I will lose the game
so here Knight to e5 was played nicely
if I was played with a similar idea like
Knight to the c5 but tonight's the c5
was the correct way to go night to see
if I would the idea that after C first
played now you snatch the pawn here on
g2 and after key and after Knight
characters now you can capture and III
I'm going after the b2 pawn and after
rook captures rook captures black will
have some compensation for this
sacrifice as he will most likely win the
b2 pawn and perhaps in some miraculous
way he can even hold this
Simeon went for a similar idea he played
Knight to e5 and here a kirkin went for
the exact same idea like the knight was
on c5 he played c4
but a stronger idea seems to have been
night captures on d5 and after Queen
captures night Stewie for going to going
for f/64 this monster for cure Knight to
f6 and after you defend this nice to d7
now comes the robbery
III the other rope is coming to f1 and
it seems to be an excellent position for
white but ok kirkin knows what he's
doing of course so he finds a different
plan c4 and forces the exact same
variation as we've shown that black
wanted to get bushel captures sacrifices
a piece we have King captures and now
comes the night captures ng - ok night
captors on d3 attacking the rook and now
rook to e3 the Queen from h6 is guarding
the rook on e3 Queen to c5 pinning the
rook and now comes the king - h1
unpinning nice to have to check a king -
h2 and now comes Queen to d6 again with
check you have to move the king we have
Kings to g1 and now comes Luke captures
on e3 Queen captures on e3 and now
Knight captures on h3 with check so what
do you do here if you capture here then
Queen captures on b2 is coming you allow
black too much activity for this so
instead the kurakin decides to move the
king we have came to h1 and now finally
King to g7 Kerrigan calculate precisely
that you will not get checkmated after
this rook comes to h8 and he plays a a
very straightforward defense against
this simply rook to e1 creating this
battery threatening Queen to e5 that
will check the king and force a queen
trade and there's a really no good way
to avoid this avian goes rogue to h8 and
now we have Queen to e5 check Queen
captures we have rook captures on e5 and
now comes Knight to g5 would a
discovered check night to f2 also seems
to be a very nice move after king g1 now
comes Knight to d3 with an attack on the
rook and against this b2 pawn and after
rook is 7 going after the c7 pawn
captures captures and now after up to h3
defending the b3 pawn black keeps his b3
passed pawn and if white wants to go
after it then the c4 pawn becomes a week
perhaps
perhaps the correct course of action for
black but okay after rook captures and
if I would have night the G if I would
check for seven King to g1 and now rook
to d8 attacking the knight on D to rock
to d5 offering a trade of rooks rook
captures pawn captures and now comes
King to have six
so now Kerrigan has two knights and
three points against a knight and five
points and okay you're gonna lose a lot
of these pawns as they're isolated pawns
but the game becomes very interesting we
have nice capture Sun b3 of course
Knights to e4 and now comes nine three
three and King to e5 King to g2 getting
the King into the game with f5 you have
to push those passports nice to see one
and now f4 we have nice to see - and now
King captures on d5 Knight to be four
check King to see for attacking the
knight and now Knight captures on a6
King to b5 and now Knight captures on c7
with check King captures on a5 and now
comes Knights to d3 we have nice study -
although King to f3 was also a very nice
move for kurakin instead of this night
to d3 King to have three attacking the
knight and picking up this pawn but
Kirkenes idea is works just as well
nice the d3 we have nice the detail and
now comes nice to e6 if you play Knight
captures an f4 immediately then the King
can come to before block the pawn and it
will be very hard to do it to do
anything here so after this nice the e6
move we have King to b5 Nike captures on
f4 9th the c4 going after the b2 pawn
and now comes the Knights the e6 the
problem with capturing this pawn if you
play Knight captures on g6 black can
simply play Knight captures on b2 and
after white captures it even though you
are up two pieces you can never win this
game and the easiest way for you to
understand why you can never win this
game is to set up this position against
the computer any computer on your on
your smartphone or against any program
any really any program will do and try
to win the win this would white or would
black but you know we
have to have two nights in the King
against the king so try to do it and
then you will know why it is impossible
so after Knight to c4 you have to keep
you have to allow black to have at least
one pawn to keep continue this game and
push for the win nice to e6
after Knight to c4 nine three six was
played we have nice capture Sun b2 not
capture Sun b2 and now g5 black again
offers upon and indeed if nice capture
Sanji if I was played then this would be
a draw but white needs black to have at
least one pawn so when he corners the
king with his own king in two nights it
will not be a stalemate
stay still meet rather black will have
his one point to make a couple of moves
and then white will have just enough
time to remain over the Knights to
deliver checkmate how this is done
kurakin shows us with a great style
we have Knights to d4 Czech pink the c5
and now Knight back to f5 the first the
first part of this end game is - you
have to block this bond with the denied
so if you just allow black to push it
you will either have to capture it or
allow black to promote it to a queen and
then you will have to capture it and
then again it will be a draw so first
you have to block it and then use only
your king and the one night to push the
King all the way back to the to the last
rank so we have g4 now comes nice to g3
the pawn is blocked King T it came to d4
and now King to f2 now we have King to
c3 a king tonight's the d1 check King to
d3 and now 1331 so first you have to
create a wall against the black King and
push him back King to c4 now comes King
d2 we have pink to d4 creating an
opposition but now nice to see three and
again the King and two nights are
creating a wall here the King has to go
back King to c4 now comes Knight c2e2
King goes back and now King to c3
pushing the King even further back you
can see that the two knights are again
creating a very nice wall here the king
is also helping out with the wall so the
King has to go back King goes here now
comes Knight to f4 King goes back now
come
came to see for boosting the king
further back King be six we have nice
the d3 King goes back and now comes
Knight the ISA
Knight to e5 with check King d6 and now
King to d4 again you can see that the
knight and King are creating a wall here
the King has to go further back King e6
we have Knight the c5 taking away the d6
square from the king and now comes
Knight to the III King goes back and now
comes Knight to f4 again you can see
that the king and the knight create a
wall the King has to go further back so
or you can go to the right but still
White will eventually corner you King D
7 we have pink the d5 and now comes came
to see 7 of course white black wants to
get as far away from the white knights
as possible but yeah of course car cane
will not allow it
King d7 and now comes Knight the e6
again taking away the c7 square for the
king the King also creates a wall here
and now comes King to e7 nice to see 5
taking away the D 7 square from the King
again the wall is created here King to
f7 and now comes King to d6 again White
King manages to get through to the 6th
ranked King to f6 and now comes tonight
C to e4 and you can see that the king
and the two nights are very nicely
creating a box against the black King
and now the black ink has a very few
squares that he can use King to f7 King
to d7 now getting the 7th ranked King
both f8 and not nice to d6 again taking
away these squares the King has to go to
the right King g7 King e6 came to g6 and
now Knight d2 e for pushing the King
further back as now both Knights are
creating a wall here so the King cannot
approach his own pond or the or the
other white knight King g7 now comes
King a 17 to g8 and now here Kirk in
misses a very nice mating fight with
Knight to a5 but still you if you've
played it out all the way here you're
not to interest it's the you know
to make it in five rather than in ten or
eleven so it doesn't really matter
King to her six was played and now comes
King to h7 it doesn't matter if you play
King to f8 and try to escape to the
Queen side White will not allow Knight
to d6 he will simply prevent you he will
completely block away these squares and
therefore you go back then comes Knight
to a5 King to a faith and now nice the
g7 again taking away the eight square
from the King and you will have to go
back King gate and now comes Knight d6
taking away all of these squares and you
have to go all the way into the corner
so after King to f6 not King to f8
rather King to h7 was played na comes
Knight to f5 finally the other night
joins the attack and now you will see
why it was very important that black
keeps his extra pawn and the white it
doesn't capture it we have King to g8
came to e7
now comes g3 black finally decides to
push his passport again he would be very
happy if black would white would capture
it as the game would then again be a
draw nice to have six check we have King
to h8 and now we have King to f8 and it
was in this position that Samuel Savion
decided to resign the game because now
the King can't move he is completely
boxed in the night and the King are
cutting the King away from any squares
and once you play g2 if you didn't have
this pawn here then it would be
stalemate of course
so here you would have to play g2 a
white would play Knight to d6 you would
finally get a Queen here but now of
course nice to f7 is checkmate as the
king has nowhere to go and he is in
check so a wonderful position and I'm
definitely going to use the these two
knights and the Queen for a thumbnail so
so you would you know of course get
interested in what is happening here
so I'm after King to a [ __ ] King to f8
that SML 7 decided to resign the game
and a very nice game for the formal role
Chess Championship challenger Sergey
Kerrigan so now I really really remember
when I was going through that book by by
borislav we've got theory of endings it
was a really impressive game and after I
think I mean
any game you can get onion games will
really improve your end game and you
will not not be afraid to enter any end
game you will you will have much better
understanding of a bishop against an AI
tonight against the bishop bishop
against abortion bishops of opposite
color bishops of same color two rooks
against two rooks rook against a rock in
the pond so those are all very important
aspects of the endgame but one of those
aspects was of course two knights
against the king and two knights against
the king and a pawn and it's one of
those weird things in chess where it's a
draw if if if you're only up against the
King but it's a win if black has a pawn
which is even a passport but yeah that's
how chess works it's always interesting
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Kevin Wright
and Robert Fisher for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank y'all for
watching and I'll see you soon hopefully
with some more interesting content and
as usual there will be a lot of
interesting links you can click on in
the description below thank you all and
I'll see you soon